[Music]
former cnn chairman and time magazine
managing editor walter isaacson is
author of the new biography benjamin
franklin and american life
he spoke about it recently for about an
hour
thank you so much morris that was very
nice and it's an absolute joy just
wonderful to be back in philadelphia
many many visits to philadelphia doing
this book every one of them you feel
suffused with the excitement the life
the legacy of benjamin franklin
especially when you're in a great
library like this since he helped found
the notion of great libraries in america
this and the library company and the
american philosophical society and so
many great institutions of the city
whenever i come back to this city i love
just starting at the very end of market
street like he did right at the wharf
there and walking up those blocks of
market street and thinking of him
straggling off the boat all wet and
bedraggled and
it's a wonderful scene the greatest of
all scenes in autobiographical
literature
of course he's got those two coins in
his pocket and he gives one of them to
the boatmen as a tip for helping row and
they try not to take it because he had
helped row
and you know he insists that they take
it and he uses the others to buy the
famous three puffy rolls and gives one
of them
to the hungry woman who'd been on the
boat and delightfully he says
you're always more generous when you're
poor because you don't want people to
think you're poor and so you pretend to
be more generous and that was sort of
like him always concerned about doing
good doing well by doing good but also
appearing to be a great man as well and
it's that wonderful mixture of the
appearances but the appearances that are
deeply rooted in a reality of a generous
pragmatic decent guy and also when you
have that scene and you look at the
manuscript of the scene and
he then adds a little something about
how deborah reed the young girl was
standing there laughing at him as he
walks up the street here of market
street thinking that he made a
ridiculous appearance and then franklin
adds in as indeed i did you know because
that wonderful self-deprecation and so
then you reflect on the fact that it's
not only this wonderful scene but you
think of benjamin franklin years later
you know in his 60s at a
summer house in england writing this
scene
and mixing in all the wonderful notes of
image and self-deprecation sort of
trying to remind his tory sympathizing
aristocratic son to remember the roots
that they came from
that
he was middle class or we the middling
people as he liked to say that we
shouldn't try to create an aristocracy
here in america but we should build a
new nation based on
uh people like himself who had been
diligent hard-working shopkeepers and so
that scene in that walk up market street
and just seeing all the institutions
that grew up around him here just makes
you think of
not only the greatness of the man
but that real human quality i mean the
other founding fathers people sometimes
ask you know why'd you write about frank
well the other founding father fathers
you know they're all up there in marble
carved in marble on a pedestal this guy
is flesh and blood and uh people say gee
you know he had a problem with his son
and his marriage was sort of you know
not always perfect and so
don't you have problems with that and
you say wait a minute you know people
like that you know we're all uh flesh
and blood humans and at least this is
the founder that you can relate to and
especially when you're breathing the air
of philadelphia
of course he doesn't really start here
he starts in boston
and
as a wonderful self-taught kid
he was the tenth son
of somebody
a candle maker from boston
and his father was thus going to make
him the tithe to the lord send him to
study for the ministry at harvard
fortunately perhaps benjamin franklin
was not exactly cut for the cloth
one day they were salting away all the
provisions uh for the winter and putting
away and young benjamin franklin said
why don't i say grace over them right
now we get it done with once and for all
for the year so his father realized it
would be a darn waste of money to send
him to harvard which is probably the
best thing ever to happen to him
uh instead he has to become self-taught
this is why he loves libraries of course
his older brother was a printer he gets
apprenticed to his older brother and so
he gets to borrow overnight some of the
books from the booksellers that they
print the books for
and there he is at age 12 and 13
you know taking these books and trying
to teach himself and remembering each
one of them you know plutarch's lives he
reads and bunions pilgrims progress and
all those books that all of us were
reading when we were 12 and 13. years
old and he decides he's got to make
himself a great writer too because he
wants to be a writer
and what he does is he takes old copies
of the spectator that great british
magazine and he reads the essays by
addison and steele and takes notes on
them and puts the notes aside and
occasionally recreates the essay in
poetry so he can
increase his vocabulary and then finally
tries to replicate the original essay
from his notes from the poetry and
compare it with the original to see how
well he did and to correct himself when
he felt he hadn't been able to
replicate the argument quite as well and
then he said every now and then though
i did feel that just in one or two
particulars i was able not only to
recreate the argument for but perhaps
even improve it which made me think i
would be a tolerable writer
well he not only became a tolerable
writer but the best writer in america of
his time
and the first writer in america really
to have that wonderful folksy
straightforward pragmatic practical
conversational style
uh be that is his may his brother being
an older brother and the way older
brothers are
was jealous of them did not want him to
write for the newspaper so young ben
franklin now about 15 or 16 years old
decides to create a pseudonym and
secretly
submit essays for the paper very
famously of course
disguising his handwriting writing under
the name of silence do good now this is
a very say cheeky
perhaps even
[Music]
let's say randy or something 15 16 year
old kid who's never spent the night
outside of boston writing as if he's a
widowed woman living in the countryside
of massachusetts a great triumph of the
imagination a widow who's being courted
by a minister in the most ridiculous
fashion so you think wow this guy has a
great imagination
but not only does he have a great
imagination and a wonderful spunky sense
of humor
but each one of these silence do get
essays of this young kid
has a real point to it that a point that
helps create what america is all about
first essay he talks about or silence
new good talks about how she has an
aversion to tyranny and any trampling of
her rights makes her blood boil
exceedingly and it's that notion of
liberty and freedom that's going to
become part of the american character
and then of course since boston's a
theocracy at that point you know a
puritan run
a commonwealth the first great crusading
against the notion of church and state
being together instead of having a
separation and there's silence do good
poking fun at governor dudley for being
a clergyman who goes into government and
saying anybody who uh
is first a clergyman can rob all your
money that way and then take all your
money in government it's a worse form of
hypocrisy and that's why we have to end
it but you you know and it's so
delightful but you have to read it
carefully to see oh yes we're creating a
new nation here even in this mind of
this young 16 year old a nation built on
religious tolerance on the separation of
church and state and aversion to tyranny
all of these things which you'll be
happy those of you here in philadelphia
to know was not exactly the way
everybody in boston felt whether it be
his brother or the ruling authorities in
boston who a couple times tried to shut
down the newspaper so finally of course
benjamin franklin runs away to come down
here to market street
eventually
and
be a runaway apprentice trying to make
his name as a leather apron shopkeeper
here in
philadelphia and
it's great that he comes here because it
helps reinforce this core notion that i
feel is at the heart of what benjamin
franklin is about and why he's so
relevant in a century this century in
which the fight against religious
intolerance and the fight for pluralism
and
against fanaticism is the core fight of
our century around the world and in all
places where it's challenged he comes to
philadelphia and it gets reinforced
because here you have a city a city of
brotherly love
as the name is implies
in which they're not it's not just a
puritan theocracy but they're
congregationalists and presbyterians and
anglicans and also moravians and jews
and people of all faiths all working
together and he just thrives in that
element because he becomes a little
shopkeeper he understands how to serve
customers he understands the tolerance
the notion of pragmatism the notion of
compromise of even making a deal that
comes from being a shopkeeper serving a
diverse clientele
and that's what instills in him some of
these great notions that he gives to us
as a nation and you take the very first
newspaper i mean you know here's a town
of 10 12 000 people had two newspapers
he felt he wanted to start a third soon
it has many newspapers was that we had
many newspapers in our big cities today
but that he believed in that voice the
many voices the competing voices the
diversity of voices that came from a
robust press
he takes over a newspaper and in one of
his first editorials somebody complained
about not liking something that had been
in the paper
and he writes apology for printers a
great editorial in which he says
basically you're not going to like
everything
that's put in this paper but by the way
if printers only printed things that
everybody liked
they'd be very little printed in this
world today because people's opinions
are as varied and as diverse as their
faces
and those of us
people like himself creating a new
nation based on the free flow of
informations and the free discussion of
ideas he said you know we believe
that when all sides are heard and with
truth and falsity all have fair play
that the people are going to be smart
enough and truth will triumph over
falsity and once again it was that
underlying tolerance and pragmatism that
leads him to the notion of a raucous
free press and a press that tries to
allow the people that believes in the
people that if the people have many
voices the people are smart enough to
decide instead of having censors or
gatekeepers telling them what they have
to think
of course he also believes that a
responsibility came with that and he
tells a wonderful tale
but how somebody tried to get him to
print something
that he found too scurrilous and not
true but was going to give him a lot of
money to print it
and so he said i went home and i bought
a little loaf of bread and made myself a
gruel of bread and water
and just ate that for a day and slept on
my great coat instead of sleeping on a
bed just slept on the floor on a coat
and i realized i didn't need the money
that badly i was never going to
compromise my principles or do things
just for money and that that
responsibility comes with the press as
well and those of us who are journalists
or recovering journalists whatever i am
you know need to remember that both the
duties and the responsibilities and the
joy and the exuberance that comes from
an open press and a society that allows
the clash and the free flow of ideas
that is so fundamental to our democracy
once again it's something that on these
streets of philadelphia franklin
understood intuitively and helped
endowed to this nation
he also uh
created for himself because he really
believed that the
middling people the middle class people
were going to be the backbone of a new
nation that if he could get the
tradesmen and the shopkeepers and the
artisans of philadelphia
to uh engage in self-improvement to be a
little bit better and more diligent it
would help create a stronger society so
he comes up with all of his virtues the
virtues he's going to teach himself and
then try to have the other people in his
group learn and he makes a wonderful
list of 12 virtues of industry and
frugality and all the things you need to
be a successful
shopkeeper and citizen
and he's very proud of it and he works
on it every week marking down how he had
done on each one of these virtues
eventually putting on a piece of slate
he said because in his wonderful
self-deprecating style he loves to poke
fun at himself he said i had to put on a
piece of slate because i was making so
many marks and it was you know
working through the paper of the
notebook that he needed a slate where he
could erase some of the marks and start
clean again
but he finally gets it right he gets
these virtues and he's showing it around
to his friends and one of his friends
kindly informs him that he's left off a
virtue
that he might want to have and franklin
says what's that
and the friend says
humility
perhaps you should add that one to your
list and franklin of course adds
humility to the list and says i was
never able to conquer this virtue i was
never able to master
humility
but i was very good at the appearance of
it
i was i could fake it i could feign
humility
and but here's the key part with the
appearance and the underlying reality as
is at least in my mind the theme of
franklin's life joined together and he
said the appearance of humility
and caring about
humility and showing humility was in
many ways as important as the real thing
it caused you to listen to other people
to care about what they thought to
realize you may be fallible
to realize you may have to make
compromise and i often think of america
in this world today you know um
george bush talked very eloquently about
the need for humility in our foreign
policy
and after the terrorist attacks i think
quite rightly and understandably the
country and president bush and the
administration had a more assertive
foreign policy
but now after we've done so there's a
question of
at least perhaps we could fake a bit of
humility and listen to some of our
allies so we can get some coalitions
together to help us i think it would uh
at least help people in the world feel
that we care what they think about so
even if we can't truly have humility as
the world's great superpower
perhaps we could be like franklin and
fake it a little bit better
he also had a wonderful as you can tell
sense of humor and i think that humor
also in a way
comes from the humility and the sense of
tolerance and everything else because it
was a special
type of humor that became the american
style of humor it was a new type of
humor in many ways it was that folksy
sort of naive character like silence do
good or later poor richard or many of
the other pseudonyms he invented folksy
and naive and feigning a little bit of
innocence but with a sharp and wicked
pen that's poking fun at the powerful
and the pretensions of the elite and at
the arrogance and stuff with a little
self-deprecation thrown in the type of
humor you've seen in everything from
mark twain to will rogers to the present
that is very american because it gives a
sense of community and tolerance and
that sort of good-natured
poking at the powerful
that keeps american democracy so healthy
you see it in so many of his pieces and
he combines it with the notion of
religious tolerance and everything else
there's a witch trial at mount holly
which i love a little tale he wrote
these are all kind of hoaxes that half
the time people thought were real
stories and only a few years later or
many years later realized they were
hoaxes by benjamin franklin but the
witch trial at mount holly has probably
funded religious intolerance where they
decide to see if
some people are witches
they're accused so they're going to dump
them in the river and if they sink it
means they're actually innocent but if
they float
uh
it means they're witches which seemed
like a no-win proposition
but those who are accused said well
that's fine but you have to throw the
accusers in as well and see so they
throw them all into the river and most
of them uh float
and um
franklin or his narrator says with the
rye
wit of franklin
some of the people kind of figured out
that maybe it just meant that human
beings naturally float but others
weren't so sure and they decided they'd
try it again in the summertime when they
could do it without clothes to see who
floated who sang and even poking fun at
the double standards that happened at
the time benjamin franklin was the
father of an illegitimate child uh
william a very interesting character who
uh as i said was the
guy who became somewhat aristocratic
pretentious loyalist to the crown and
franklin was
sort of half aiming the first part of
his autobiography at him
but uh he does a story called the trial
of polly baker who also had had
illegitimate children five illegitimate
children but she's on trial and she's
been put in jail for it and she kind of
mentions well you know
i believe the promises that were made to
me and uh there are five men who um
uh and they're not on trial and somehow
i am on trial and she gives a stirring
defense of what she has done to help the
city and how she was the one who was
misled and why is she the one on trial
and said the man
and in a certain point one of the
magisters comes down from the bench
with great emotion and proposes marriage
to her and they get married one suspect
said he may have been one of the five
i'm not quite sure but uh but it's just
this wonderful way of poking fun
at some of the potentials of the elite
while also establishing
a new feel for what american democracy
would be about
uh the best of all of course is the poor
richards almanacs
uh which he printed in his shop right
here in market street
and poor richards is one of his uh
pseudonyms and great cutouts
and the great thing about poor richards
is basically his philosophy was doing
well by doing good meaning he can make a
buck by doing good for his fellow
citizens he taught a whole lot of maxims
you know the early to bed early to rise
which i'm not sure franklin fully
obeyed most of his life and a penny
saved as a penny earned it was partly
there to help
people the shopkeepers and tradesmen
become better citizens but as poor
richard says in the very first preface
of the very first almanac in 1733 he
wasn't just doing it to be helpful he
was doing it because his wife threatened
to kick him out of the house and throw
away all of his instruments and stuff if
he didn't make some money at it
eventually and so he's doing it to make
a buck as well
and
you see that
great style of franklin
uh poking fun at himself but also being
an entrepreneur who believes you can be
an entrepreneur but also help your
community and be a good civic citizen
and
that uh out of that eventually he
retires or semi retires from the print
trade he's franchised the shops up and
down the coast from boston to barbados
uh created a great media empire that
would be the envy of the media empires i
used to work for and others in which he
had both wonderful printing facilities
and then franchises up and down the
coast and then the content before
richard's almanac or his own writings of
the newspapers
and then the books that he imported to
publish and then eventually being a
great media tycoon the distribution
system which he wanted to help control
so he helps create the us postal service
for that
once again a case of doing well by doing
good but he takes some time off after a
while
from these partnerships because he wants
to turn himself into a great citizen and
civic leader
and do well for his community he writes
his sister a wonderful letter describing
his motivations he's saying he ends by
saying i'd rather it be said of me that
i lived usefully than that he died rich
and what he does is he forms many of the
groups including
the library we're sitting here and the
others i talked about
that help philadelphia and help america
become better communities better towns
and uh a greater country
and among those was the junto
a great little discussion club
which is supposed to help you know the
tradesmen of philadelphia discuss the
important issues of the time the
timeless values
and how they apply
to the problems they were seeing at
their time
and uh just speaking personally for a
minute having spent 20 25 years in the
media world and i was thinking making a
transition it helped me a lot too and i
moved to a place the aspen institute
which mars mentioned which is very much
modeled and very much like the junto
it's a it's
it's engaged in discussion
it's engaged in looking at values the
values of our of our civilization from
plato to the present
it brings people together from all walks
of life who want to step back for a
little while and have a vacation for the
body mind and soul in order to
recharge their
connection to their values if they've
sort of lost the feel for the values
sometimes in the business world they
feel it's good or to just discuss the
great ideas great books and great values
and how they apply to the issues of our
time and people keep coming to aspen for
these seminars and anybody i urge you
all to come you can just go to the
website and look them up and come but
it's the type of thing that benjamin
franklin felt was important that you did
you didn't just try to succeed you also
tried to connect to certain values and
connect those values to the community
because in the end people were going to
judge you not by whether you died rich
but why but by whether you lived well
and served your fellow citizenry
and of course the library because he
connected that to his uh rather
amorphous but deep belief in god
i think when he founded the libraries
here he had a wonderful slogan which was
basically to pour forth benefits for the
common good is divine and that helped
him figure out that even though he
didn't know which particular religion or
which particular church here to join
there was one particular creed he felt
all churches should have which is the
best way to serve god is to do well by
your community and your fellow citizens
now that also came in the founding of
the university of pennsylvania
and i love the difference
of the way he founded the university of
pennsylvania and to compare it to his
friend and protege thomas jefferson
later found at the university of
virginia but jefferson felt that the
point of a university like that would be
to skim a new aristocracy to create in
his version of a meritocracy to take the
most talented people and remove them
from the rest of society elevate them
skim them off a bit
and make them into this new aristocracy
not franklin he was the most democratic
he had the best fingertip feel for
democracy of all the founders and for
the university of pennsylvania it was to
help any aspiring person any inspiring
person who was going to be diligent and
work hard whatever their station in life
to help improve them to become better
citizens and he wasn't trying to create
a new class society or a new elite but
just a better society all around in
which people from all walks of life
got a very practical
and solid a chance to be better citizens
he finally goes over to england after
that to
help
he was a man of great
hope for the british empire and he
basically felt all problems could be
solved as i said about the aspen
institute or the junto by looking at the
underlying values and saying we can find
common ground and he mistakenly thought
that he could find a common ground that
would save the british empire and keep
what he called the fine noble china vase
from shattering apart thus never being
able to be put back together he finally
ended up using the humor again those
hoaxes just like when he was silence do
good
one of my favorites is a newspaper
article he wrote it was after england
imposed a lot of taxes and tariffs and
they had justified the taxes and tariffs
on the colonies for a variety of reasons
uh including the fact that they had
colonized you know this part of the
world and they had protected against
wars and they had the right to impose
the taxes so he wrote the edict from the
king of prussia which appeared in the
papers it was an edict from prussia in
which prussia announced it was
imposing attacks and tariffs on the
english because they had colonized
england and protected in certain wars
and he was in a country home at that
point in england and somebody comes
running down with the paper and says
look at this and they're reading this
thing aloud with great outrage that the
king of prussia would have put out such
an edict and they look at franklin in
the corner smiling and they realize that
uh once again his pen his sense of humor
his way of humor using humor to make a
point had been so successful
uh
he of course uh finally gets humiliated
over and over again in his attempt so he
comes back to america in 1775
and casts his lot in favor of the
revolution
here in what is now known as
independence hall of course first he has
to have the summit meeting with his son
and this is great soap opera that have
alluded to the son william the
illegitimate son the son he adored and
educated and took responsibility for and
then tried to prevent from becoming too
aristocratic by now william has become
the royal governor of new jersey
and is very loyal to the crown and they
meet up in bucks county for the summit
and
they don't reconcile they can't get
together and franklin declares that he's
going to be a rebel
eventually william is arrested by george
washington's troops and this horrible
rift in the family happens made even
more poignant by this beautiful grandson
william's own son in fact william's own
illegitimate son temple franklin
who benjamin franklin the grandfather
had helped educate and raise and there
was this tug of war for the loyalty of
temple franklin and of course benjamin
franklin wins
uh the tug of war for the loyalty of
temple
and uh they're there then in
philadelphia in 1776.
when it comes time to write the
declaration of independence
and it's the greatest committee you'll
ever find three the three most important
people on the committee were thomas
jefferson john adams and of course
benjamin franklin to write the
declaration and on market street here
using a little lap desk that he invented
jefferson writes the very first draft
the initial draft of what they're going
to do and he sends it to franklin a few
doors away
and in this beautiful flowery letter
said with the good dr franklin and all
of his infinite wisdom please peruse
this document and any
improvements he could possibly make and
blah blah blah and i thought boy people
were much nicer to editors back then and
franklin sees that famous second
paragraph and jefferson has written
we hold these truths
to be sacred
and undeniable and franklin takes his
printer's pen that wonderful black
printer's pen with the heavy backslashes
that a printer uses and crosses out the
last few words and changes it that we
hold these truths to be self-evident and
he wants to make the point
that it's the consent of the govern from
which these rights emerge
their natural rights rights of reason
and rationality not just rights endowed
by religion and once again
that from that early silence do good
sense of tolerance and rationality and
pragmatism you see it reflected now in
1776 in that great document
they finally
later that year he goes to france to get
france in on our side in the revolution
i think he was the last diplomat who
really knew how to handle the french
um
and he did it masterfully first of all
he played a wonderful balance of how
he's a realist he played a balanced
power game
a balance of power game that would have
dazzled the matterneck or kissinger
playing off the interests of spain the
netherlands france the bourbon-packed
countries
and england
making it clear to virgin who was then
the foreign minister and king louis xvi
why wasn't france's interest to be on
the side but more importantly he
realized and this is a key to what
america is all about in his role in the
world and the role we're going to have
to play in this new century
that the strength of america
has been always will be and even when it
won the cold war its strength was the
appeal of its ideals not just the force
of its interests and power
that people like the ideals of america
the ideals of liberty
aversion to tyranny
the things that franklin stood for and
he he promotes these throughout france
he prints the declaration of
independence all the state constitutions
on this private press that he creates in
his
uh in paris because he wants to inspire
the french people with the ideals of
equality and liberty that are bubbling
up so famously in france at the time
and he becomes the most famous
uh
american ever in well with all due
respect to jerry lewis ever in france
and um
people are paying
to see him go through the streets
they're paying for good spots on the
street when he's being brought to the
academy
to
hug voltaire and franklin is no fool
he's always worrying about his image
whether it be about humility or
industriousness rolling the carts of
paper to the streets of philadelphia or
his um generosity and uh
when he first arrives here
he knows that the french sort of love
rousseau and the idea of the natural man
so here's a guy benjamin franklin who
really has lived in philadelphia in
london his whole life on market street
and craven street for that matter two
well-named streets but he pretends to be
the great back woodsman as well and he
wears the fur cap and the frock coat
from the back woods and sort of and even
when he goes into the salons or whatever
none of the wigs or fancy ceremonial
swords he's wearing his fur cap and
people are touching it and
thinking of him as a natural frontier
philosopher and they create all these
medallions and portraits of franklin and
it just became the thing in paris
everybody wearing franklin medallions
it's so annoyed king louis xvi and
amused him that when one of the
countesses who was part of the court of
the king at the time kept on and on
about franklin and wearing the medallion
the king actually had a chamber pot made
with an embossed franklin medallion at
the bottom for her but it works
france
france's ideals are appealed to its
interests are appealed to they come in
on our side in the revolution i don't
think we would have won militarily the
way we did without france i think 90
percent of the gun powder
came from france
certainly
lafayette had as many troops at yorktown
french troops as george washington did
and emeril lagasse blocked it off
the retreat
franklin was famous of course because
poor richard
had been collected and published there
as lacianze de bonhomme richard
and so they raised the money for john
paul jones to have a ship
that helps win the revolution and um
and in gratitude he names it the
bonhomme richard after benjamin franklin
by the way uh there's another there's a
great book out by a friend of mine evan
thomas that describes the importance of
john paul jones and sort of the grandeur
of this crazed friend of benjamin
franklin in paris some wonderful scenes
of them together in paris
but so france comes in on our side in
the revolution
becomes
our savior
and
it
it really shows that of all the things
franklin did great scientists you know
great writer everything else
he was the most accomplished diplomat
and we have so much to learn even from
that on benjamin franklin when he
finally does come back to america he's
now about you know just past 80 years
old so it's about time for him to retire
but he doesn't
they're gathering here in philadelphia
to do the constitutional convention
and as uh jefferson once famously said
of the people who gathered they were
sort of demigods and franklin was there
to remind them that they were actually
in the presence of a god greater than
themselves and of history and that all
these great heroic men of principle who
came here to philadelphia
and were so
dedicated to their principles that they
wouldn't compromise
the whole
is almost breaking down on the question
of the large states wanting proportional
representation smaller states wanting
equal vote per state and congress those
type of issues and finally franklin the
great sage becomes the voice of
compromise
and what he says basically is that
compromisers may not make great heroes
but they do make great democracies
that's what democracy is all about
feeling that maybe the person
who's against you and fighting you on a
matter of principle maybe they have
something worth listening to as well and
maybe that's how you make a democracy he
said you do it the way when we were
young tradesmen and we tried to make a
joint that would fit together well for a
table or something
and if it didn't quite fit you'd have to
shave a little off of one plank and then
take a little off the other plank and
you kept doing that until you made a
joint that would hold together for
centuries and so too we at this
convention must each part with some of
our demands and realize
with a little bit of humility that we
may be fallible
and so they did and he makes the motion
that has a house and a senate
and other things he also
keeps fighting for the notion of
democracy when most of the founders at
the conservative convention were a
little bit worried about the concept of
democracy he kept saying let's not do
anything that demeans the spirit of the
common citizen no wealth uh
uh requirements to be able to vote or
hold office all that sort of thing and
he gets all these things done as a
compromise
his compromise is passed and then he
makes a wonderful closing speech which
everybody should read
about why they should all line up even
those even those who oppose this
document and sign it
and he said uh
you know
i'm getting old now is what he basically
says and i'm not sure that this is the
best of documents but in my old age i
realize
that i may be wrong and that some of the
things i see as flaws
i may be mistaken and maybe this is the
best possible document and maybe when
you gather people together and you get
the wisdom of all people like this
you end up with a document that is near
as perfect as you can get as we've done
here today so let's put aside our
differences and admit some of our
fallibilities
and not be so arrogant and line up and
sign it and make it unanimous and so
they did almost all of them all except
for a handful all line up
to sign the document that very hot
summer day in philadelphia by the way
this is before air conditioning so
imagine today in this room yes
and as they line up and sign it he
points to the back of general
washington's chair and he says
i've often wondered whether that was a
rising or a setting sign
because artists have trouble and there
aren't distinguishing between the two
but now i know it's a rising sun they
finally open the doors because they've
done this all behind closed doors one of
the grand old ladies of this town mrs
poundl comes up to him and says what
have you wrought what have you given us
what have you done in there he says the
republic madam if you can keep it
and that was his sense that was all
about democracy the wisdom of the common
citizen it'd be up to us to be able to
keep it there was however at that
convention and in franklin's lifetime
one issue
that could not be solved by compromise
and it was the issue that they failed to
solve it was the issue of slavery
and
franklin had fought tyranny his whole
life but he had made many errors in his
life which is why i like him he was the
flesh and blood founder as i said the
one who made errors admitted to those
errors and tried to rectify him as he
said
so
in his eighties after the convention
he decides to become president of the
society for the abolition of slavery
because he had owned two slaves once in
his life and he had allowed his
newspaper to carry advertisements for
slavery and he realized that this was a
blot in a lifetime fed spent
fighting tyranny so he becomes president
of the society for the abolition of
slavery and does a remarkable brilliant
wonderful petition and speech
talking to congress and everybody else
about the ideals of america and how
incompatible and uncompromisingly
incompatible they were with slavery and
how slavery had to be abolished and all
slaves freed etc a congressman from
georgia got up right afterwards after
this thing is published and gave this
speech attacking franklin
talking about uh how the economy would
be in trouble if you didn't have slavery
and how slavery was needed and how the
slaves who were here were better off and
that sort of thing
so from his death bed
last thing great thing he writes lying
in the death bed here on market street
he writes yet again
another wonderful hoax that for a while
full of people and in the paper he
publishes
he says that he discovered and this is
just echoes of silence do good at age 16
here he is in his eighties discovered a
speech given a hundred years earlier in
the divine of algiers by the one of the
great legislators of algeria
defending the need to continue the
practice of enslaving white european
christians to work in algeria and it
goes step by step through the arguments
that have been made defending slavery in
america and was quite a sensation
and to me it was a fitting end to a life
begun as silence do good fighting
against tyranny and all forms of
trampling of our rights making our blood
boil exceedingly to do that parody and
hoax uh the speech of the divine of
algiers on his deathbed
and when um in his lifetime here in
philadelphia
he had contributed if you look at his
ledgers to the building fund of each and
every church in philadelphia
and even at one point he raised money
for what was then called the new hall
right next to what is now independence
hall
and it was for itinerant preachers
preachers who wanted to come in and
didn't have a pulpit and in the brochure
in the pamphlet he writes soliciting
money for it
he says even if the mufti of
constantinople were to send somebody
here to preach mohammed to us
we should give that person a pulpit and
he should have a place to speak and we
should listen and then right before he
dies he's one of the largest there's a
top three donors uh to the mikva israel
synagogue the building fund of the first
synagogue in philadelphia so in the day
he died when they bring his coffin to
the grave
usually your minister marches with the
coffin
all the ministers and preachers of all
of philadelphia and the rabbi of the
jews
all walked arm-in-arm holding his coffin
to the grave and that to me is a spirit
of philadelphia and the spirit of
religious tolerance the spirit of what
franklin gave us and the spirit of what
we need for our new century thank you
all very much
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
well i'm delighted to say that
mr isaacson has agreed to answer
questions and just as our
tradition during uh our other sp speaker
series we have a volunteer on each side
with a microphone uh and we want you to
you know when you're ready to when you
want to ask a question raise your hand
mr isaacson will call upon you uh but
please you do need the microphone uh so
that everybody can hear
and that uh uh also it it will carry
across the room thanks
yes yes sir right there that's how you
nodding during the speech
worrying about what you were going to
ask
i forgot
could you comment on the portrayal of
franklin in the recent book on john
adams by david mccullough's book is a
masterful wonderful book and i'm sure
most of you have read it i think
everybody in america has read it
um
and i've always admired
david mccalla in fact asked him to read
some of this manuscript and my
manuscript and help on it a bit he bears
none of the blame for the problems in it
but he was helpful
obviously there was a complex love-hate
relationship between john adams and
benjamin franklin a wonderful weird
relationship
it begins
as i said he comes back to 1776 they're
doing the declaration they're working
together lord hal has come over from
england
with a peace feeler
and he had played chess and franklin had
tried to negotiate a piece with him
a few years earlier and so uh he sends
it to franklin franklin gives it to the
congress
and they authorized franklin to go talk
to him but they're a little bit worried
especially john adams that franklin is
too much of an accommodator a
compromiser so adams travels with them
this is their first real
bonding experience a bonding experience
because they get they're on the way to
staten island and they get to the end
and there's only one room with one bed
so they have to sleep in this bed
together
and it's great because you see it in
franklin's letters and in adam's diaries
franklin had just come up with the
theory
of the contagious nature of the cold
which happens to be correct
that that colds were caused not by cold
air but by germs so he insists they keep
the windows open the entire time adams
who will have none of it kept wanting to
close the windows franklin says i guess
i haven't explained to you my theory the
contagious nature of cults and they
lying in bed and he starts explaining
and adam's delightfully especially for
adams who is not usually as humorous
with all
uh as franklin sort of said and after
about half an hour i finally fell asleep
while he was on and on about his
contagion and so he thus won the
argument uh and they get to they work
together of course in france uh although
adams gets himself kicked out for a
while and they have a great uh conflict
over how to deal with the french as i
said franklin basically loved to seduce
people nations the french he was going
to charm the french into understanding
that we shared ideals
adams was much more of a realist
hard-nosed
uh
not in any way trying to charm the
french but just you know no suitoring
for alliances for him and um
in fact one of the great distinctions is
franklin famously learns to speak french
by lounging on the pillows of his two
great girlfriends there madam hilvisius
and madame brian and exchanging little
love notes which they would correct his
french and john adams learned french by
memorizing french funeral orations so
you see the difference in the way they
do it but by the end they share a couple
of things a deep patriotism and an
enormous intelligence and the greatest
assessment of franklin in some ways
comes after he dies by john adams i have
it near the end of it in the book and
the conclusions
where adam says like you know i mean i'm
paraphrasing but i was really tough on
this guy and i had to be because he was
the greatest man of our time but in
retrospect and he gives us great payon
to the greatness of benjamin franklin
and is a very nuanced understanding of
what made franklin so special
obviously in my biography
you know i'm a little bit more partial
to franklin uh than
uh david mccullough was partial to adams
uh that's why i recommend you read both
books
uh yes in the in the middle and
right behind you first see how this end
up there
hi uh i haven't read your book yet but i
was wondering if you discovered
something about franklin that uh
something significant that is not
generally well known
and also something that we might
attribute to him that he may not have
said or done
i think the most interesting thing
that's not all that well known about
franklin i spent a lot of time
researching and had some help from a
researcher in london as well
is the notion uh that his secretary
edward bancroft
while he was in paris
and negotiating with the french and then
the british was a british spy which has
been known
but
interestingly bancroft every tuesday
wrote reports of exactly what franklin
did what was happening
in paris what was happening in the
delegation wonderful uh
little things on john adams by the way
he didn't like john adams
uh and he wrote it in invisible ink in
the blank spaces between love letters
and he put it in a bottle in the
toiletry gardens in a hollowed-out tree
and the british
agent would retrieve it and send it back
to london and they're all in the public
records office now in britain and they
use the chemical wash to allow the
writing to come out so i went through
all of those to see exactly
uh what was being reported on and what
happened to franklin one of the great
things about franklin is he assumed and
he kind of knew and he had been warned
that there were spies in his mess he
assumed there was british spies and
french fries and he used it to his great
advantage playing them both off against
each other when he's about to conclude
the peace treaty the treaty of alliance
i mean with france to get them in on the
side of the revolution he's letting he
knows the british know exactly how far
along he's gotten he's very open about
it and
the person who's running the spy
stormont comes over from london to try
to prevent this and wants to meet
privately with franklin silas dean and
some others in the delegation and sends
a note sort of saying a friend wants to
meet you you know it's a very secretive
spy sort of thing and we'll meet you on
the side of the road at this part of the
road being in this type of carriage or
if not there in a bath house on the sane
river in this cabin with a key that the
attendant will have and silas dean who's
working with franklin at the time and
trying to write back and say if you want
to meet you can come to our offices at
noon a response worthy of an american
so they just assumed they were very open
about things and it worked i mean they
played the british and french off
against each other massively but i love
that wonderful spying stuff and now some
of it is relegated to footnotes because
it was so rich but it would clog up the
narrative so it's buried there in the
footnotes but the spy and some of the
others were also speculating on the
stock market so before they sent the
word back to the british spy overlords
they were sending it to uh wharton and
the other bankers in london so they
could short the stocks when things were
coming in
and it just became a look at both
franklin benignly assuming that he was
being spied upon and in some ways a bit
too uh i think careless about it but
still it ended up working and what these
spies all did
uh there's probably a lot of myths
attributed to franklin um
but uh in some ways the opposite is more
true you take the electricity
experiments and we think of them as the
daughtering old sage whatever
the discovery of the single fluid theory
of electricity which is basically
franklin's great insight
is in some ways the most important
scientific discovery of the time that
and he even invented the words we still
use to describe it positive and negative
flow battery condenser
plus minus that sort of thing that
electricity was a fluid and flowed as
opposed to what they called vitreous and
resinous and two separate fluids and all
sorts of crazy ways they were looking at
it plus he also believed that what uses
science what uses philosophy if it
doesn't lead to some practical good he
kept saying and so he said at first he
couldn't figure out having done these
great discoveries in electricity what
practical use they would have he said so
far
it was two things he used it at the end
of one season of experiments to build a
huge battery in which they jolted and
killed turkeys for their celebration so
we southerners like to think of him as
the inventor of the deep fried turkey
um
but he said really the only use we've
discovered for electricity so far is
that it helps make a vain man humble
because it knocks us out all the time
but eventually he figures out okay the
charge and that the ability of pointed
objects to draw a charge from charged
bodies he figures out that lightning
comes from a excessive charge in a cloud
and it's a discharge and stuff so he
figures out the lightning rod and comes
up with extreme which is basically the
most important technological invention
of the time i mean lightning rods so you
know it was an amazing thing and saved
the world so i've skirted answering your
question about where he was overrated to
give you a chance to give myself a
chance to talk about in some ways i
think his electricity discoveries are
underrated
way in the back there oh i'm sorry this
gentleman here and then way in the back
yeah could you comment on the rumors or
the stories that are going around i
believe prompted by your book that the
kite and uh key story was a hoax oh
there's a problem there's other books
out about it
uh i don't know there's one book and i'm
not quite sure it sort of says maybe it
was a hoax it's not quite clear blah
blah
there's a great book for those who are
interested in the kite experiment how he
reported it why he held off reporting it
for a while etc there is one great book
about all of the science
two books actually by the same guy that
puts it all in perspective i bernard
cohen who just died not too long ago but
wrote uh franklin and newton and i like
the order in which he put it and then
benjamin franklin science which
explained i think in great detail
because he published franklin scientific
papers
the whole kite experiment issue but
there's obviously been some debate on
historians because he doesn't report it
right away
and it's important to note that he never
claimed that
his experiment was the first to discover
this he created an experiment
that was basically a lightning rod type
thing to draw lightning from the clouds
he published it as how it should be done
and it was done in france
uh because they were able to build a
platform the century box is done in a
village called marley france because the
king at the time was had been shown
benjamin franklin's experiments were so
excited about it he commissioned them to
try this century box lightning rod
experiment it's successful he becomes
the most famous person in the world
because of it
he's celebrated all over it gets back to
philadelphia a couple months later that
this has been this huge success and then
a month or so after that i think it is
he says it's great it was done in france
and congratulates him he said after they
did it
just sort of a by the way we found
another way it could be done instead of
erecting this whole century box which is
to put up the wire on a kite and draw it
down the string of a kite so his
description of the kite experiment was
not supposed to be the first drawing of
lightning from the clouds experiment
and he only reports it after he learns
they've already done in france and
doesn't claim it was the first one but
it's a rather complicated thing and
there are some debates about when and
how and why
and there are many books including a
recent one but also as i say going back
to the i bernard cohen work on his
science yes back there was it and i
think you have to wait for the mic which
is right behind you
um
carl van doren uh who wrote an earlier
biography of uh franklin
right right before world war ii right
after it 1934
i think it was yeah he called franklin a
harmonious human multitude
and my question is he was a much better
writer than i was carl van doren
he was an english professor one of the
newer books coming out about franklin
d
do you think that you and and uh morgan
the other authors
um have a more
complicated view of the harmonious human
multitude
i mean i tried to take him as a very
human person
to say the carl van dorn book is a
masterpiece
it's an english
you know he was an english professor and
really is particularly good as franklin
the writer and stuff i was more
interested in
the
multiple facets of the man and his life
including his family life but also his
diplomacy his science
his newspaper work his
creation of a great media empire things
that i felt tied into our period today
um i think there's ed edmund morgan has
a unbelievably insightful book that came
out a couple of years about a year ago i
guess it is now
that uh a reading of all the papers one
of the things that's happened well
since vandoorne's 1930s
biography is that all of franklin's
papers have been collected at yale or
almost all of them there's i think it's
47 volumes they're going to do and
they're up to about 37 right now in fact
it's on a cd-rom that's not yet been
released but
i've been able to you know they lend out
and so you can read everything he wrote
and even search it by phrase or keyword
that sort of thing and so it does help
the exploration of franklin but more
importantly
and i try to do this in my last chapter
i look at how each generation each
decade even has looked at benjamin
franklin
and each generation
because he's the most human of the
founding fathers the most delightful of
the founding fathers
each generation we see ourselves
reflected in him carl vrandorn wrote his
book during the depression
it had come after a romantic era when
people like d.h lawrence were making fun
of benjamin franklin is and all that
penny saved his opinion stuff as being
frugal penny-pinching maxims and thrifty
little things that we didn't know to
need to deal with and then you look in
the depression and people like carl van
doren taking them on and it's
and i think our generation each
generation should look a new at franklin
not only because of the inspiring values
we get from him but that flesh and blood
sense of the person and even his flaws
and we can see an ambitious urban
entrepreneur
somebody who
very comfortable in an information age
somebody comfortable with technology a
great networker a great uh
you know many things you can see
reflected for better and for worse in
our times and so uh although i love
people to read uh you know call van
doren and certainly edmond morgan and
certainly uh hw brands many people have
done really great books i make no
apologies for the fact that you know
uh we should write about benjamin
franklin often especially as he's about
to
celebrate his 300th birthday
right
which needs a microphone
part
of the question which was how would you
like to see us celebrate the 300th in
2006
i think it's gonna be celebrated very
well there's a consortium here in
philadelphia i think i'm going to lunch
tomorrow with some of them they're doing
an unbelievably good job the franklin
institute the american philosophical
society i'm going to leave some about
university of pennsylvania library
company
many others have formed a consortium the
government is not helping enough but
helping some to fund it
and we're going to be talking about that
now i i would suggest that what franklin
would want is for a lot of people to
give a lot of input because he believed
that
you know part of celebrations like this
was inclusiveness and making us all feel
like citizens
i have my ideas which is you know we
should look at the effect that he has
today on a variety of fields from
technology to science to
uh information to freedom to
fight against tyranny and most
importantly at all as of all is was the
theme of my talk tonight
the celebration of religious tolerance
and pluralism that makes our country
strong in the world today and i think
there are many ways to do that both
through exhibitions and panels and
discussions i don't want to preempt that
because there are people who are much
better at figuring these things out who
are working on it and i
i'm flattered to be invited to be with
them tomorrow and talk to them but i
don't know what they're planning but the
small things i do know about what
they're planning is it's going to be a
hell of a good birthday party
yes ma'am over there
uh
i think i can speak loud enough about it
just as a practical like you use
pragmatic and practical so much how many
years of research and writing did it
take you and
my curiosity leads me to ask you also if
you are
thinking of or planning another book at
this time or writing one at this time
well i spent i've been working on life
with henry kissinger and was interested
in the roots of realism in american
foreign policy but also the fact
that kissinger was a great balance of
power realist but i don't think had a
fingertip feel for the openness
democracy and values that lead the true
strength in a foreign policy so i was
looking for the roots of the idealism
and so it was even back then that i had
been reading benjamin franklin a lot
because he was the first great diplomat
to do it and then i became as a person
involved in the publishing empire
uh quite interested in him that way so
starting 12 or so years ago i was
studying him seriously my whole life
like many people you're just absolutely
smitten and fascinated by benjamin
franklin
uh and you feel you have to rescue
yourself from having read the
autobiography in school and figuring out
okay the autobiography has many many
layers and he created a delightful
character in the autobiography that he
named benjamin franklin but that doesn't
necessarily mean that that was exactly
who benjamin franklin was so i did it
for 12 years i had some day jobs in that
period and um
some of which made me want to uh get a
respite at night and it was a lot of fun
i mean you know people said some people
ask you how do you well
a labor of love it's like you know
building a model ship or playing golf
some people love doing things that you
know they'll spend a lot of time on i'd
spend a lot of my evenings you know
starting he said early to bed early to
rise you know makes a man etc
i found that a lot of hui i used to just
um
start work at nine o'clock at night and
work until i got really really tired and
but it was fun and if you you start
reading benjamin franklin you'll say boy
that's fine you see what i do speaking
of which the next thing i think i'm
going to do and want to do with my our
publisher and get together is one of the
problems of benjamin franklin is you can
read the autobiography you go to any
bookstore there's all sorts of paperback
copies of the autobiography we've been
doing but if you want to read the things
i was talking about the silence do good
letters or the busybody essays or the
apology for printers
or
uh poor richards almanac and all the
prefaces and all the maxims or
polybaker's trial or the edict from the
king of prussia or uh the witch trial at
mount highly or the speech to the divine
of algiers on white christian slavery
you can't really find that that easily
there's a great library of america
additionally came out 15-20 years ago
but it's you know expensive it's not
right so i'd like to put together the
best writings of benjamin franklin and
if anybody's curiosity was piqued over
the past few years by the various books
that have come out on benjamin franklin
maybe go back to the real thing now and
he can say it better than we ever did
and so i hope by the end of the year
we'll put out a nice and and inexpensive
you know uh anthology of
his best writings
is uh any more
i do want to say uh
benjamin dr franklin is actually with us
i saw him walk in
and so if you have more questions in the
very back
uh philadelphia has a great pride and i
won't uh take him out of character i'll
just call him dr franklin
somebody who answers questions about dr
franklin better than anybody i've ever
seen do it so uh
further questions can be directed at dr
franklin standing in the sitting in the
back thank you all very much
[Applause]
walter isaacson is president of the
aspen institute benjamin franklin and
american life is published by simon
schuster on the web at simonsays.com
[Music]
c-span 2 is 48 hours of non-fiction
authors every weekend
here's what's ahead